لا تنظر الى دموع الصياد بل انظر الى ما
تفعل ذلك
بتتعلق بهذه الحكومه وان كانت حكومه يمنيه
متطرفه ولكن هي تضم ايضا اللكود واللكود
هو ليس حزبا متطرفا هذه الفئه التي دخلت
في هذه الحكومه وفي هذه التركيبه لها
اجنده وانا اعتقد ان هي لن تتوقف عن
المطالبه بجندتها السياسيه وستشكل لاعب ان
على هذه الحكومه وعيب على نتنياهو
ربما ان هذه الحكومه لم تسقط في وجه
التحديات التي تواجهها اولا فيما يتعلق
بالمظاهرات التي تتزايد للاسبوع وتتصاعد
الاسبوع الثالث على التوالي ضد السياسه
المعلنه بالاصلاحات على الجهاز القضائي
ثانيا قالت وزير في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بامر المحكمه العليا شكد ركن اساسيا من
اركان هذه الحكومه ممثلا في هذه الدرع
[موسيقى]
انه جاء الى عمان لم يذكر في بيانو اي شيء
عن موضوع القدس او موضوع حل الدولتين انما
ذكرناه يبحث عن علاقه استراتيجيه او تعميق
العلاقه الكلام الجميل المنشئ هذا انا
اعتقد زياره نتنياهو من جانبه هي محاوله
لكسر العزله الداخليه والخارجيه همم التي
يعني يخضع له حكومته طوال هذه السنوات
تعاملت معنا الحكومات المتعاقبه همم على
قاعده كسب الوقت ان يقولوا بعضهم كلام
ماسول ولكنهم على الارض المتطرف اليمين
واليساري والنصف يمين والنصف يساري
برنامجهم على الارض نفسه التوسع في
الاستيطان قضم الارض
توصلنا في ال 2015
ببساطه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في ذلك
الوقت جون كيري الى اتفاق يتعلق من المسجد
الاقصى التزم نتنياهو في هذا الاتفاق ده
عدم السماح لاعضاء حركات الهيكل بتدنيس
المسجد الاقصى والتزم بعدم السماح لليهود
باداء الصلوات في لكن كما تعلمين منذ ذلك
الوقت حتى وحتى اللقائه مع الملك بالامس
همم مئات المرات يعني توفيق قيامها
الصهاينه باداء الصلوات داخل المسجد
الاقصى
والسماح يعني الحركات الهيكل ليس فقط
تدريس المسجد الاقصى بل الاشراف على تدميس
هذا الامر لانه احد هؤلاء وصل الى الى الى
سده الحكم وهو ثمار
المتحده تبدو منهمكه فيما يحصل في اماكن
اخرى في العالم لا تعمل حركه اوكرانيا
وكذلك صعود الصين وتحديات التي يطرح ذلك
امام المصالح الامريكيه اذا القلق الاول
او احد ابرز مخاوف ولاده الموت المتحده
بالنسبه الى وصول حكومه امنيه متطرفه الى
اسرائيل
فيما اماكن ومناطق اخرى من العالم
ان هناك تهدئه في المنطقه عليها ان تجبر
اسرائيل
اجراءات ذروه هذه الاجراءات الجلوس على
الطاوله لاقامه الدوله وانهاء موضوع
الاستيطان وما ينسج ما قرارات الشرعيه
الدوليه
[موسيقى]
قمر داخل فلسطين
ينبع بانفجار كبير جدا لانه لكل فعل رد
فعل اشقاء الفلسطينيين انا اعتقد الى ما
بقيوا بهذا الوضع الضاغط عليهم بمائشتهم
بحياتهم استمرار الاحتلال
توسع الاستيطان انا بظن اننا امام انتفاضه
الثالثه
العيون وبالتالي لا اعتقد انه هذا انه
الدنيا اصلا في موضع حتى لو كان صادقا انه
في مكان انه يلزم يتمار ابن كبير وممثلين
اليمين الديني في الحكومه باي شيء لا
ينسجل مع توجهاتهم
[موسيقى]